[Music]
hello
welcome to monday classes
i am dorsa darashini and i am here to
impersonate caleb denby
um too bad he couldn't be here for
this one but um i heard you guys have
been doing night or
so i'm gonna do my best to try
and hold on to what caleb has been doing
all right um
so i decided to show some of my
personal games um two against
my current teammates so i go to sluis
and lee's university
and the two dutch boys that we have
robbie cave literally
and benjamin book i actually played with
them
back in 2015 and
uh kind of funny how i actually
um got a pretty good score against them
considering they were both higher rated
than i am well
let me rephrase that back in 2015 robbie
was a little bit less than me in rating
well he's higher now so
well still so i managed to have a very
quite beautiful win against robbie and
gets a draw against benjamin so
i decided that it would be kind of cool
to show those for now
okay so um
without much more let's just jump in
so this is the first game that i want to
show you this is
the game that i played against robbie
this was in
the tournament cultural village and they
can see
this is like if you win this tournament
you would qualify for
vacancy b i did not win this tournament
but it was a very great experience i
remember
mr sutovsky recommended me so thanks to
him
uh yeah it's kind of interesting how you
meet people
in the chess society and you just play
some tournament and then some
some little kid back then now ends up
being your teammate
whoa oh hello from nigeria great okay
so um oops i am
on the wrong board all right there we go
um so
in this sicilian i
actually um full disclosure it was quite
nice preparation and um
i knew what i i took a look at his
scores on chess bass and i saw that his
recent games
he he had bad scores against this f4
so i kind of chose to
give this a try to give this a try
oops english and
um well actually kind of paid off so i'm
glad that i made that choice
um and yeah so
this is something that i've talked about
in some of my
other um videos too that's
actually understanding your opponent
weaknesses and understanding your own
strengths
is really important is just as important
as actually preparing before like you do
calculations you do openings you also
need
to do this kind of preparations against
opponents
so um preparation is important guys
not gonna lie about it not gonna
downplay it so in
this game i chose f4 mainly because
i saw that he had bad results against it
so after e5
knight back to f3 knight d7 all of this
is normal theory
um i assume something like with queen c7
is also possible but or like queen b6
these are also possible
but knight d7 is the most
popular one yeah
um there are a lot of the openings that
we play right now or i'm
telling you like right now it's kind of
changed because it's been like
four or five years so a lot of different
things have came up
lot of strong engines have gotten
stronger so
if you choose to look at some opening if
you like it
make sure that you check the games
that's happened
since then or that's one of the things
that i had a lot of problem with growing
up like i would see this cool game in
drew lopez i wanted to replicate
it and guess what nobody plays that
anymore
so yeah make sure you keep your
repertoire and your chest knowledge up
to date as much as possible
okay um so my idea with a4 was to
basically stop b5
and potentially do this bishop c4
so um still i was it was kind of
still deep in preparation so still
i'm not completely um sitting down
and using my own brain at the chessboard
i've used my brain before the transport
to get to this position
um so
yeah this is not grand prix grand prix
is with nice c3 f4 you're correct
and i've played grand prix before i
played sometimes
these days in blitz and blood too all
right
um yeah we do this early f because
um early f4 it's a little bit
um not it's not so popular um
more the most popular ones are just are
like bishop g5 instead of f4 bishop e3
f3 long castle
but the f4 is also a little it's kind of
like
to me it was a very interesting little
sidearm so after take take
so in this kind of position you can
immediately see this
square is weak black uh kind of owns the
square
this pawn is weak so it's a matter of if
you can eat his pond
or if he can defend the pawn and cover
it up with the knight e5
um you can't really stop knight e5 right
now but
i'm going to go ahead and ask my first
question from the chat
do you guys think taking on e5 is a good
choice
or not so basically why to move and what
do you want to do
i'm reading the chat and
okay
yeah okay so i saw a no that's good you
wouldn't take great
so if you wouldn't tank then what would
you do you have limited choices on what
to do with your bishop
okay i see a bishop b3
okay all right yeah i think bishop b3
would be the
most interesting um taking
on e5 is not very desirable
because you're kind of fixing that
problem you're also giving this bishop
this diagonal and let's not give
opponents
free gifts really against giving
opponents free gifts
so yes we do have to move this bishop so
we can't go to a2
or we could think about bishop d5 i
believe bishop d5 was
still something that i looked at before
game and now if knight takes all right
great i'll just take that with the
knight i'm attacking this guy
you move the queen i can simply take on
well actually i can take on here never
mind this is even easier i just pick up
the pawn
if you get creative and do something
like queen b8 to be defending this
i could simply take on e7 or even do
knight b6
there are way too many options
another option is trying to just
castle but yeah you have lots of options
lots of good options
so yeah for something like queen b it
also doesn't work so black should not
take the bishop on d5
um something that's uh kind of funny we
talked
in this the more this morning camp with
um some of the kids was the concept of
prophylaxis and
trying to do some um provoking opponent
into making a mistake so bishop d5
is something like that you're trying to
provoke your opponent to making a
mistake and take here
so that's why we'd like bishop d5
robbie was a smart kid he didn't take it
he castled
simple castle and he played bishop g4 so
question from the audience what should
we do now
this is a very normal position and
there's not
i can't say white is better or black is
better both have
equal fighting chances and we are both
we are trying to just create more
weaknesses for the opponent
and we are also trying to put some
pressure
so now what should we do
black played bishop g4 putting pressure
on
f3 um i think it's
worth considering uh taking on e5 but
i don't think we should do that just
because if you take on e5
after take you fix this problem you fix
this
you fixed this bad pawn you are also
giving
this bishop some
this diagonal and we don't really want
to do that so exactly thank you
uh yaroslav we are going to
play king h1
so um after king
h1 let's say black
simply plays something like rook c8
right because whoops
okay rook c8 because through it is
interesting
and the thing is well if black just
takes over here
we'll just simply take back slippery
mouse
and then we're just going to play rook
g1 we're just going to put the rook on
d1
essentially put the rock on g one this
is very
um this is very just simple
simple stuff you're just developing and
putting more pressure on black
so there's not much to think about for
black like
bishop g4 was interesting because it's
putting pressure but at the same time
black doesn't really have an intention
of taking it just yet
so uh rook c8
in the game i went with queen f2 because
guess what i had actually just finished
reading um the
it there was the giants of strategy book
there they actually actually have like a
whole chapter on
prophylaxis and um
provoking opponent to make mistakes so i
had actually finished reading that book
before this tournament so i was kind of
um humped to just just play something
like
this provoked pro i can't say that
provoking opponents into making mistakes
the book is called giants of strategy
i've done
few games from them in my videos and
okay um
actually in the game robbie did take
here after take back
he went bishop e6 i don't think it would
have made a difference if something like
bishop
h3
and after bishop h3
rook g1 and now this is actually some
serious issues for black so black
wouldn't want to push
for bishop h3 so black played bishop e6
rg1 take finally now
white to move what do you think we
should do here
you have some choices on what to do with
white
you could take back with pawn with
knight
anybody sees any intermediate moves
intermediate moves are great
they're chess players best friend
intermediate moves anybody see something
any checks any threats queen jitter is
interesting but the problem with queen
g3 is simply knight h5 and stops the
whole thing
thank you axel bishop h6 yeah
queen g3 is not very um
desirable because first glance knight is
five
you gotta play like queen g4 then bishop
goes to ec whoops bishop goes to e6 and
even if you take then there's g6
so that's not really um very
yeah we don't want we don't want knight
h5 we prefer bishop h6
uh g6 is forced now you have a choice do
you want to take on d5 or you want to
take on oops f8
um about candidates the last thing i
heard was that it's postponed again
players requested to feed it to postpone
it and
according to my last info it is
postponed but no idea when
oh i see there is a healthy debate on
what to take nice
kind of 50 50 but i i know we should
take on f8
taking on f8 is better because if you
actually
move this bishop i'll also take on e7
and now your dark squares are also weak
so i can like start pushing over here
so we could simply just take it there we
don't really have to
worry about
we don't really have to worry about
not taking back so
black has to take back now we simply
take here
take take and this was the game and in
the game i think robbie made
a little bit of a harsh decision and
he's just played queen takes c2
i think exchanging queens was not very
wise something like queen c4 might have
been a little bit
um better just because going after d5
going
after c2 just trying to keep pressure
like if i play rook a d1 maybe now you
can think about taking on a4
so i think this would have been more
interesting but still i would have
played something like queen d2
i mean white is still better but black
would have better fighting chances
all right so um let's go back
take tank robbie took on c2 take
take yeah exactly kind of i kind of got
all i wanted
rick c1 and he also took
on b2 which was like christmas morning
for me
um taking i went just like i
just went to the background got that
whole um
back rank 2. if something like king g7
it still doesn't make any healthy
differences because
still bishop can't run away everything
is kind of stuck
so in the game robert just played rookie
2 trying
to get the chance to play bishop v7
i um kind of rushed a little i should
have played rook b1 her b1 would have
been the best
choice and after b5 take
take take for example then i could have
pushed for that
but i really wanted to keep that a pawn
and potentially
just make it a healthy baby queen
so i just played a5 with hopes of
uh just eating b7 and a6 and making a
queen
so the pieces do move on slow mo not
sure why though
so drop a plate king g7 um
or p8 bishop e7 let's just eat that
i'm gonna go a little faster over here
because all of these are just normal
moves
i am eating puns he's trying to attack
my pawns
uh rookie 2 wouldn't be possible cause
the bishop is under attack so he tried
to free the bishop first
but still it's a little too late um
here is pretty much it's not that hard
to find a win
for k7 take there i take that guy
um just have to remember not to
basically blunder your pieces and
this was a pretty chill win for me
i just brought the king over a little
bit
brought the king closer trying to avoid
checks
and this is something that i actually
talked about
in the last week tuesdays just in
psychology
about repeating moves and how it gives
opponent hope i'm going backwards now
so i gave my opponent some hopes that
hey maybe i want to draw
when i actually had no intentions of
making that draw
so it was kind of nice to
do that little psychological trick too
anyways
this the game is pretty much over i'm
just trying to
show you how it ends and actually this
slow-mo is kind of going against my wife
but this is not really hard to win this
though right you just just win the rook
and just try to even healthy checkmate
soon all right and he actually resigned
here because after f5 falls
all of these are falling and it's kind
of
would be a little bit insulting to
continue but this is a very nice game
and he's a very nice kid so if you see
him if you know him
don't mention this game to him
all right uh it was a good game so now
let me show you
another game that i had with another
teammate
back in 2015 when i had didn't even
i don't think 2015 sent loose university
they actually had a chess team
so all right so this game
is uh was played where seuss benjamin
book
another dutch man another teammate and
this is also a very good game um
he was very close to crossing 2600 and i
was kind of
on my hunt for my 2400
and he he got his i got mine
i got my title uh i am title
unfortunately they don't really give out
titles for 26
crossing 2600s that's that's something
that i've actually thought about a lot
maybe a super gm title for
uh 2650 2700 would be actually quite
quite nice anywho um
back to real real lives instead of
fantasies
so in this game this was actually in
chigo and memorial
this was actually before when i played
robbie i should have showed this first
so um now
we are looking at another night dwarf
but this one it was kind of a little bit
more like cheveningen
compared to night or i was very prepared
for neidorf
and i wanted to play a new line that i
has working on with like
trying to play oops then something with
bishop to e2
and queen d3 which i'm hoping to show
you right after this game
which means i have to kind of rush
through this um but
it unfortunately didn't happen and he
just went for e6
i remember in the game he kind of just
really really thought a lot about when
uh what to do so
um i assume he wanted to kind of
run away from my prep
good thoughts because i was quite
prepared
um yeah a lot of people are doing
instead of bishop e3 there there's so
many lines there's a
g5 there's bishop e3 there's bishop v2
despending if you want to short castle
you want to do long castle
you can play rook g1 you can play h3 you
can do
f4 kind of running out of moves here but
there's f3 now let's not forget about
that depending on what you where you
want to put this light thank you yes
there's also a g4
i believe there is early moving the
knights back to e2 yeah
it's a it's a headache there's so many
so many niger lines for
caleb to cover but
for me oh yes queen f3 forgot about that
for me i am just showing some of my own
experiences
i have talked about najdorf and
different videos as well there was a
game that i played with bishop c4
uh there were quite a few games that i
played with trying to do like h3
and f4 so feel free to check those out
too
or should be on in youtube for
the club anyways g3 forgot g3
okay there's so many moves i'm gonna
keep forgetting one or two of them so
i went with bishop v3 and after e6 i
simply played bishop d3 so back in the
day
i wanted to try this queen f3 long cast
like queen h3 f4 idea against najdorf or
cheveningen
so um i
just wanted to stick with what i
prepared
and i just kind of just went along with
it
here actually knight a4 would have been
better so for those of you who
are trying to find an interesting idea
against nydorf this could be it
you could think about having this bishop
e3 bishop d3
queen f3 queen h3 um you could do long
castle or short castle i was going to do
short castle and then f4
so you can't
think about that all right
bishop d3 b5 f4
b4 knight back now this is another
square that we can
try and hop into
all right so bishop e7
gotta defend the pawn now knight d2
especially because knight c5 was coming
and
now um why two move what do you want to
do
should do would you want to take this do
you want to move the knight
also i do agree bishop d3 is not the
most ideal place for the bishop
but uh you're always going to have one
piece that's going to be
like with kind of like lagging behind
for a bit and in this game the bishop on
d3 is that
so your bishop is kind of in a defensive
mode
because you have this weak pawn unless
you're going to play f3
and that would be the whole different
reasoning and
yes knight f5
we shouldn't really take here because
simply knight takes back and
you're giving this a square to your
opponent that's something that you
as neither someone is playing against
neither or playing against
most sicilians you should know to
it's you should just be aware of that
giving this a square up
it's usually gonna be quite painful in
the long run
so unless you know exactly what you're
doing you shouldn't really give it up
that easily
so he went for g6 let's get the knight
back
and he played bishop g7 i think d5
was also a potential
um move but then we just with castle
or oh f5 maybe yeah i think f5 is also
interesting
so yeah i think f5 is kind of
interesting if d4 just bishop g5
whoops yeah i think this is good for
white
another thing is if black tried to play
like h5 followed by
h4 we could still try for f5
we could push for knight c4 try to poke
around here a little
no this would these would all be kind of
cool
anyways okay
um yeah yeah exactly mattel
d5 is usually something that black wants
to
achieve in a sicilian especially in
najdorf
so got the knight to g3 bishop g7
now question why to move what should we
do
i think a move such as castle is normal
but we could simply think about
something a little bit more
a little bit more how to say
tricky maybe uh yeah f5 is also
definitely possible
but that's not the move i went for f5
would have been interesting
but i was a little worried if he just
ignores it and castles or what if he
plays d5
i was a little worried about these and i
decided to
try and play something a little bit more
tricky i went for knight c4 just because
attacking d6 and if you push d5
now i can also just eat that
not that he would make this mistake but
it's always too
good to just lay out the trap so
uh after knight c4
um best move was to play something
between queen e7 or queen c7
and he chose queen c7 now we can just do
castle
uh long castle is actually not a good
choice
because after longcastle shortcastland
black has
advantage black is clearly
more advanced than attacking you than
you are attacking him
d5 is coming this guy is coming it is no
it's not it's not very pleasant you
still have to figure out where to put
this knight
and yeah black has a clear
head start on your
king so don't want to have that so let's
just do short castle
short castle and now um
why to move what should we do
i i think you have quite quite a nice
choice
on trying to take on e5 or push on f5
or maybe develop a rook or something
so yeah what do you want to do
uh you gotta be careful if you start
doing some stuff
with um like knight e2
g4 it's a little it's kind of a little
rushed
so gotta be careful with those
hmm maybe a3
no yeah so keep keep in mind
you should think about um
always as you think about takes checks
first and takes
then moves the threads you should at
least keep an eye out for them
so do you see any reasonable checks well
actually
any legal checks no any reasonable takes
yes fe 5 is a reasonable take so you
should
think about it a little bit at least
before dismissing it
roughly one is okay move but keep in
mind that
black wants to play d5 so if you just
play
too chill black's gonna just play this
d5 and
yeah it's not gonna be very pleasant
no f5 there is still d5 so
d5 is a serious threat right now so we
should take that
seriously and that's why we should take
it
if you were to play f5 there is d5
if you take oh boy you can just take
that to the bishop
now this is falling so you have to play
queen e2
now this is falling you can't really
stop that
your bishop is trapped so yes
please don't blunder don't give your
opponent free stuff
and all right so
that's why we should simply play f takes
e5
and yeah exactly so
now uh we would now let me ask you
why to move what do you think we should
do
where do you think in the board we can
try and improve
we could think about can you improve any
more in kingside
or center if not can you improve any
more
in the queen side
i see a kingish one i see rick d1
um both of those would be interesting
if you didn't have um okay so i
understand not wanting checks
but luis you're correct a3 is the best
one
you gotta this is uh this is like a um
weakness that you have to try and go
after
so how to go after it
you can think about c3 you can think
about a3 you can't really
go after more directly than that
but a3 would be better because whoops
not that if take take now you are uh
you're actually having a new um
target to go after right
so that's why we prefer a3
exactly we want to open up files for
rooks so
um now after a3 best move for black was
to actually play a5
so now what do you think we should do
remember we talked about
reasonable takes and how we should think
about them is this
is this a reasonable take do we like it
do we not like it
do you want to just play bishop d2 i
i do like the idea of king echuan but i
still think it's
um it doesn't go with the flow of the
game
so and hello albert
yes exactly keith good job take
take and bishop d2 so now
black to move black actually has a good
black actually has a very interesting
comeback
so what do you think black can do
a hint in the game my opponents played
take on a1 that was okay move
nazis that's not anything special so
you see anything a little bit special
check with queen protect pawn no
not necessarily i mean yes you can do
queen c5 but queen c5
i would simply just move the king away
this doesn't really help you yes that's
defending the pawn
but it's not really i mean the queen is
quite misplaced here
so you're going to have some problems
so
let's get back to the position with our
slo-mo
test.com board
so anything else anybody oh i see some
b3s yeah exactly
good job on those of you who thought
about b3
yeah b3 was the little tricky because if
i take it now black actually has
these weaknesses to go after so
yeah and then after this could have
taken on
a1 take back and
then something like knight c5 going
after all of these stuff
kind of funny because benjamin took here
first and then played b3
so it was a transposition and in this
game
so in this position why to move what do
you think we should do
bishop a6 instead of b3 was a valid
choice
but b3 is much stronger
so
keep thinking about intermediate moves
just because your opponent is attacking
this bishop doesn't mean you have to
move this bishop one square back
which will be four interesting but not
interesting enough sorry we need
something a little bit more
we should no i think maybe bishop b4
well what i was worried about with
bishop b4 was just simply
something rook b8 and now this is
another problem
so thank you matthew yeah bishop a5
there should be five kind of forcing the
queen to go away if you were to play
bishop c2
knight goes to e6 and then jumps over
here
or simply could take over here
and you still get to
kind of similar position as i got in the
game but
this feels a little bit better for black
because black could even just do this
sacrifice potentially
and try and jump in c5 go after here
i mean i'm not saying that i don't
i don't think
this sacrifice is too realistic in the
game
like i'm saying i don't think my
opponents would have done this they
sacrificed
giving up the exchange but
um i didn't feel comfortable knowing
that it existed
and it was good enough to be considered
um all right so bishop v5 queen d7 now
bishop c2
in the game um benjamin just
took over here i still think knight e6
would have been more annoying for me
just 96 than knight d4
voila so he took on e4 take
back take back and intermediate moves
you guys
intermediate moves because keep in mind
if you take on here
then there is this queen d4 and then
bishop takes your bishop
and technically you are not down
material actually you have one more
pawn if nope never mind sorry i just
took back the pawn
uh but it's still quite unpleasant these
bishop on e4
just monsters attacking your king yeah
we don't want that
so that's why you should always consider
intermediate moves
finally we got into this end game
and all right so white to move
what should we do
keep in mind there are still some
weaknesses around here that you can try
and exploit
so put yeah i think you should go after
this guy
so that should limit your options um
g-force doesn't really work because
you're not really threatening anything i
can simply just play like
can i just play um
[Music]
maybe just bishop d5
you take over here i'll take over there
and now go bishop d4
yeah i don't really like these two
bishops g4 kind of weakens the king and
with two bishops it's not worth it yeah
bishop c3 is the best one
he went with drook b8 and now
i decided to just push this pawn it
would have been okay to also
bring out the king and just like try and
go to the other side
but i liked the idea of having this
bishop pinned
so i simply went for b4 now i'm
questioning my opponent
what do you want to do
i could have taken on e5
i assume but i did not like the idea
of giving rook d2
so maybe we could have taken with knight
potentially
but still take take rick d2
defense this but this is a problem g3
rook goes there yeah no no no let's not
give
too much uh potential to opponent
so i just remember b4 and now we take
this because it's a check
right take take check all right so
in the game i played knight c4 but i
think knight g4 would have been even
a little bit more um interesting you
gotta move the king whoops
now i can try with like king f2 or
knight f2 and try to take that
anyways i went with knight c4 because i
just wanted to
stop rook d2
and knight d6 all right so
who here thinks this end game well
actually let me rephrase the question
what do you guys think about this end
game take
take take why two what should we do
is this end game winning losing draw
most likely draw but you would have to
play it very precise
which i actually messed up here a little
bit
um i played rookie too not the best move
what do you think we should do
rook e3 um maybe but what's your idea of
a dirk e3
just because you want to play b3 okay
ah whoa no no no bad king
but that's the thing i think it's better
to play whoops nope
it's better to play b3 first and if take
all right take draw
i agree this is an easy peasy draw but
if not take what if king goes to e5 then
what do you want to do
to e3 or rook to b1
um that's the thing if you were to play
rook e3
uh it creates some issues with like if
what if king goes to
hold on um i thought something looks
like
waiting moves like group b6 and then
just what if black keeps on waiting and
just starts pushing these pawns
your rook is kind of just stuck
so uh honestly ricky e3 is the move i
was going for
but rook b1 is better and then you would
just
sit here and wait basically you put the
king on e2
and just wait repeater p1 wait and now
this is a draw this is a very easy draw
black hands
make his position better i can't do
anything might as well just
shake hands so
i thought about b3 but i was a little
afraid of rookie three so i played rocky
too i
kind of forgot about rook b1 in the game
so after king e5 king f2 uh yeah exactly
rook b1 is inactive but at the same time
black doesn't really have anything
can't advance anything and if black
decides to move the rook
elsewhere then we get b4 b5
and everything so
king f2 he played h5
and in the game i just played rook c2
because i wanted to try and activate my
rook
and all right this position
rook takes b2 white to move what should
we do
you have to calculate this pretty good
because rook c5
is the first move you're going to think
about but after rook c5
king e6 what are you going to do are you
going to take on e4 because then you're
going to lose g2
and h2 so
you should play your c5 yes that's not
the question my question is what after
rook c5
no you shouldn't play rook c4 or vc if
you play with c4 you're going to lose g2
h2 also rexe 4 there's simply
rook b3 check it's not uh yeah that's
not really nice
just check and you got to move the king
and then the king can also come
to just like there this pawn pushes yeah
no
nope nope yeah you gotta play your c5
that's not the question though
let's say king goes to f6 now what you
want to do
this is kind of a critical position so
what do you guys think we should do why
did i give up b2 because i kind of had
to
it was a matter of choice of being super
inactive and allowing the
black king to get in or give up that
pawn and
find the right move
it is possible to take on e4 yes if you
take on e4 however
then rick takes g2 then what do you want
to do because you are
losing your h2 pawn so you better you
might as well know exactly what you're
going to do
best move here is actually to play king
f3 take
king g4 just make him wait if h3
or c3 and you just pick this up
so it is possible to take on e4 but
you could also play g4 g4 is also quite
interesting you take g5 check
you put that king in basically in a
blanket
make a king burrito out of it and you
take over here and then you just simply
bring your chain to g4 and put pressure
on this eventually you'll pick this up
with your rook and then
that is a draw end game so
in the game i actually went for rook c6
check
and then rook c5
and finally i did this g3
uh we could simply again take over here
but
if take on g2 you have to still very
be very precise and
i was a little afraid on
what i was doing and i didn't really
want to give both palms
so i really wanted to um
just try and cover up no actually g3 is
not a bad choice g3 problem
is not that it takes the problem is with
h3
so h3 then we could try actually i'm
gonna ask
what do you think we should do after h3
what do you think white's best move is
because if you take on e4 rook takes h2
and then that pawn is very close to
becoming a queen
nope we can't take on e4 you take on e4
that h3 pawn is becoming a queen
nope we're not gonna resign we're gonna
play king of four and then go to g4 and
pick this up
so yeah if you take on h2 just king g4
and it's it's kind of about um
how you are putting pressure on
opponents
if e3 or here oh hold on yes yeah
e2 and it's kind of like black can't
really
uh promote his position
and you're just simply gonna wait and
chill while black is kind of suffering
you touch this stroke you lose this
you touch it that way you lose that so
it's a very nice
um kind of zuzlongish position and
yeah i like this okay
so let me go back
to where we
draft ah there we go so uh what do you
do after rook takes edge two
what now what should we do are you going
to take on h4 are you going to play g4
you're going to take on e4
take on h4 not really i mean
yes you can but if you take on h4 then
rook takes back
and now g5 is coming and then this king
is getting activated
and it's not quite pleasant
so you could simply um
take on oops nope ah stop going back and
forth there we go
you could simply take on e4
now after take on e4 um black has
two choices between h3 and h takes g3
what do you think black should do
how are you guys liking this neither of
end game is it good
we got through two different setups in
night or so
as long as we get some end game in two
it's been a very
full class right
so what do you think let me ask you
again so let's say black
plays um let's say black takes on g3 now
what do you what do you want to do
you kind of have to come back right you
kind of do have to play this king f3
g2 king f2 again waiting and waiting for
opponents
and you have two choices you can either
just move the rook and let me eat this
or i'm going to kind of attack your rook
and then pick it up
so you are losing g2 regardless
um so and this end game is draw i'm
cutting your king you're cutting my king
also it's g
pawn so can't get any more draw than
this
actually i'll show you it can
uh alright so in the game benjamin
played
h3 i went king f3 because we need to
keep the king close because
if not then there is rook moves and this
pawn wants to become a queen right
so king g4 i think g4 was also kind of a
cool move because if you play
h2 then i have king h3 and again king is
coming to g2
and you are going to lose this pawn i
think that's
actually king g4 is a move that he
missed
when we were analyzing the game after
the game was done
but okay anyways he went with king g7
i'll just give a check ah just let's go
for this pawn
and all right i'm going to kind of uh
scroll through
the rest of the game because this is
pretty dryish
but um quite interesting we
continued until well
you'll see he says he's still pushing
he's hoping i'm going to make a mistake
but i mean it's
really hard to make a mistake in this
endgame
especially when the pawns and the pawn
on the fifth rank
and yeah this is a this is a super draw
right
and finally we all know how this works
right
we did so much extensive work on king
and pawn
warfare so yeah exactly
fragrance that's what i did i gave up
the pawn gpon and it was a draw
so yeah i hope you guys enjoyed two
different sets up
set up z in nightdorf and
basically my experience with
my dutch teammates back in 2015
maybe we should rename the video ben and
yeah thanks
uh i'm sorry that was a misfire oh no i
was just gonna
say that i'll see you back in twitch in
about five to ten minutes
be sure to tune in for that we're gonna
do tactics and i have lots of puzzles
for you
see you soon
[Music]
you